since 2014 a working group has been
developing proposals for the
rehabilitation of the Copper River today
we're at the corner of charles and smith
street upstream of the William Street
bridge don't even tell me what's
happening with this area of the river
well this is where the corner many years
ago was realigned and it it needs to be
we ended a bit more so the channel from
will be sort of dug out from up at the
masking area and come through here with
a main channel and then better off this
Corning you can see behind us here
that'll get battered off and if these
plantings that we've planted there's a
trial or work and they all do that what
they're supposed to do in growth then
that whole area will go into the river
with that with the plantings to to make
sure that we won stabilize the bank but
to we can also help with purifying water
and things like that when we yet when we
fund them putting all the plants back in
here and making sure that we got
plantings at over here banks meandering
banks great collection point for four
eggs for all species invertebrates in
which to to play and make sure that
they're read that they breed in a proper
manner and natural manner within the
river itself so nipple you mentioned
sloping the bank across the river here
what do you mean by there well what it
should do is create a much better flow a
much more even flow at the moment it
comes around the corner really rapidly
causes erosion to the bank the interbank
here and that should just slow then a
little and stop some of the big Edie's
that come around the corner and just
make a more consistent flow through the
river and am or naturalized bank on the
other side
so how can people have their safe well
right here they can come and there'll be
an open day at the Royal conifer and
people can have their input that way we
have the website we have counselors
community board members and we really
want people to have their implement
there are six proposals we'd like your
feedback on attendee are open day on the
twenty-seventh of April we'll find out
more at why Michael ed dot govt TMZ
[Music]